he is from the Houston Chronicle man has
been covering Houston sports for over 40
years John McLane how are you sir great
so how is all this sitting in your town
as you can imagine we've got a dark
cloud hovering over Houston it's been
that way since sunny Sunday afternoon
and then of course while everyone was
lamenting the blown 24-point lead by the
Texans at Arrowhead Stadium Rob Manfred
the hands down his decision and none of
that was surprising Richard there's been
a lot of speculation about Jeff Leno
being suspended for a year AJ Hinch
probably for six months to a year we all
knew they'd take a high draft picks and
find holder Jim crane but what was a
double knockout punch was when the owner
Jim crane fired AJ Hinch and Jeff ludo
pitch is an incredibly popular manager
the fans love him the media likes and
respects and players respect him
he's just been tremendous and now rich
he's going to be without a job and I
think it'll be about a year and you'll
get a managing job pretty quick because
he's great at what he does and then I
think Jeff Leno will have to go in some
front office probably working for a
general manager I used to work under him
here do you really think AJ inch is
gonna get a job after just sitting out
for a year John I mean because the III
I'm and I'm one of those who loved
interviewing him and loved getting to
you know chat with him I'm one of those
members of the media but I I can't
understand how he did not according to
the Commissioner approve of the methods
of Alex Cora and Beltran and the rest of
these players whose names we still don't
know how many there are
does it include the young shortstop in
Korea who's been nothing but lights out
ever since he came up is it somebody
like Altuve over the last couple several
years is burnished his resume into Hall
of Fame worthy throughout these years
do you think that been Hinch would get a
job I don't understand why he would let
this thing go if he was so dead set
against it I think number one owners
want to win and hitch is a great manager
and a great guy deal with for everybody
remember owners want to win so he was
still about the players you know they
worried about the Union they told
players they could have community if
they was jilted through I'm not
condoning anything they did they should
have been penalized and he should have
been suspended as an Astros ban I'm
disappointed they got fired
especially hints but the players you
don't don't have any participated you
don't know to what level on the road
they were the second-best team of the
road in baseball to the Dodgers in 2017
and a lot of them hit better on the road
than they did at home and then last year
when Rob Manfred said there was no
evidence of cheating they went to the
seventh game of the World Series and
lost four games at home so they were
good whether they were cheating or not
and as far as Hinch it's hard to believe
he didn't know about everything but
according to Rob Manfred he did not and
so if an owner is thinking about hiring
him and he calls the Commissioner's
Office the commissioner's going to say
well read the findings we found in their
investigation he didn't orchestrate it
and he didn't know about everything what
do you believe it or not I just be very
honestly John it's so hard to believe
that he didn't know everything and
according to the Commissioner he trashed
two monitors that cap errantly got
replaced
and even though the replacement of it
might have been part of just hey let's
keep the it's there for replay purposes
and it got put back by the
Commissioner's Office it's still bizarre
that he would continue to let something
go that he did not like and now now core
is paying for it too
I wonder if you think it's tainted that
the banner that's there and and
Houston's tainted I can't stated yes
it's tainted when people think about the
2017 Astros what in the world series
they're going to think it's tainted just
like very oh my entitled side Young
Awards pitcher who were these pitchers
who were believed to be taking steroids
and Max buying they're maximizing their
effectiveness we're all going to look
back on that and the Astros are tainted
can you imagine what it's going to be
like this season rich every ballpark
they go to they're going to be verbally
amused with cheaters if there's a team
that was planned with a humongous chip
on his shoulder it should be the Astros
they have eight of their nine positions
starter I the only top pitcher they
wanted to keep was Cole and so there's
still a legitimate World Series
contender but in about AJ Hinch all he
had to do was tell him hey guys check
this bleep out or you're going to be
better banished or something but he
didn't do it and I think that is the
most damning thing against him Eyre
Trevor Bauer yesterday he's been one of
their biggest critics but he said I'll
keep an eye as a player you don't know
which players did it you don't know that
he stampin did it some of them have
totally ignored it and I agree with
power and it's not going to suspend them
anyway now Carlos Beltran I can't wait
to see what the Mets are going to do
with him because he and Alex Cora based
on Rob the inference investigation
they've masterminded the whole thing
and so I'm can't wait to see what Ned
would let the match do can't do anything
commissioner can't - fell trying because
he was a player but john mcleaney
Houston Chronicle here on the Rich Eisen
show as I started the show of all the
players that didn't get named we don't
know as you point out how many players
that were in on this that did not get
named one did get named and his name is
Carlos Beltran which to me is a bright
neon sign by the commissioner to be sent
over Queens New York to essentially say
do something about this that's the way I
took that to mean John right now they're
meeting and they're trying to decide
what they want to do I'm guessing to
fall in line with the Astros and the Red
Sox that they will fire Carlos Beltran
even before he started and I just think
because they're gonna step in line do
the same thing and Jessica Mendoza of
ESPN was on ESPN radio today and giving
voice to what's a lot of folks are
beginning to say is that Mike fiers
should have kept his mouth shut
and he broke a code by talking about
this to the athletic how was fires in
that Clubhouse was he liked was he
disliked I mean what can you tell me
about that pitching and that's why they
were so surprised that he did that story
with Ken Rosenthal I told my wife I want
you to buy every ticket to every A's
game so we can make sure and be there
when buyers pitches because he's not
going to get a really warm welcome
returns as the fans will blame him of
course and fans are so forgiving they're
gonna know a lot of people are talking
tough about the Astros but of course
they're gonna give up standing ovations
when they come back and cheer for them
but it's gonna be a lot of fun with Mike
fiers [ __ ] against Ben for the first
time
a few more minutes with John McClane in
the Houston Chronicle I believe is
driving around town during once again be
careful both hands on the wheel John you
got pulled over I mean like literally
five years ago when you came on the show
doing this they'll be careful okay John
while we move through the next few time
on the same freeway interstate 10
amazing you know area where I was then
and I'm being very careful with this
very good
you know signal when you change lanes
hands no no hands-free on the phone the
hands on Tennant too as you're driving
so I saw tweet this weekend or on Monday
amidst all of this that said the
luckiest guy in Houston is Bill O'Brien
because it's blown the Texans horrible
loss off of radar screens and the sports
headlines in in Houston what what are
the ramifications do you think of the
the way the Texans went out on Sunday in
Kansas City John well Bill O'Brien as he
is after every loss gets crucified here
by the fans in the media more so this
time for several reasons number one
Houston's never hosted an AFC
Championship game if he had made that
phone edit call on the fake punt they
probably lost anyway
but everybody's blaming him for that
call which is one of the two worst in
our city's history along with a play
called stagger Lee the Oilers Jerry
Glanville called in Denver that
backfired and playoffs and so the fact
that Mike Vrabel who's in Tennessee
coaching the former Oilers two years
after he left here is in the AFC
Championship game the Texans blew a
chance to host it for the first time
we've not had a team in the championship
game since the Oilers after the 1979
season and that galls people even more
had they lost this game say 41 to 30 41
to 31 and the Ravens had not won I mean
the Ravens had one and not lost and the
Titans weren't in it then people
wouldn't be as mad they were not in that
point under dollars
right now riches you can imagine it is
ugly ugly ugly so I mean interesting
that you bring up the fake punt which
again was I believe when it was 24/7
instead of punting and playing defense
and making the whole field be what came
to city needed right in the middle of
his own territory he went for it didn't
work out then an avalanche started that
it was also exacerbated by a fumble on
and ensuing kickoff and then and on so
on and so forth but to me the thing that
leaps out John was the decision to kick
a field goal to go up 24 nothing when it
was fourth and so short that gene
starett or couldn't even fit a an index
card between the ball and what would
probably be the first down line and and
O'Brien said afterwards that they didn't
have a play they liked to call which to
me was how that was the the real
head-scratcher John how did that one sit
with you well it didn't sit well with
anybody what he said is we didn't have a
great play there and so I asked him
after the game about it asking again
first question money right he said I'm
not going to talk about specific
decisions but then he said some work
this year some didn't
the week before against Buffalo they had
fourth and one they ran a snake with
deshaun Watson it was stopped the Bills
responded by driving and taking a pill
golf that forced overtime so the failure
on fourth and one could have kept them
from winning that game over the bills
and they went up by four scores but when
he went for the fake punt he said he
wants to be aggressive because the end
score 50 points which was hyperbole at
the time and then but yet he wasn't
aggressive on fourth and one so I've
never seen special teams rich in my 44
years of covering the NFL be involved in
so many impactful plays I scored
touchdown on the block pot recover a
month muffed punt six yard touchdown
drive then they have
the 58 yard kickoff return that ignited
the sea of red and got everybody to wake
up and start getting behind the cheese
that led to touchdown then the fake fake
punt led to a touchdown and then a
fumble on the kickoff return set up a
touchdown so I'm at five humongous plays
my special teams you never see that so
what's the ramifications I mean deshaun
Watson even said Bill O'Brien's the
right guy for the job because I guess he
is smart enough to sense what was coming
or was already brewing there's there's
no there there right in Houston no Bill
O'Brien got three years left on the
contract he's a general manager without
the title he's underneath he makes all
the decisions only answers to the
McNair's and there's a lot of talk about
them hiring a general manager even if
they did O'Brien would still have all
the power and he's going to have the
power as long as he's the head coach
here and I people say well why wouldn't
mean there's by him and I'm sure their
reasoning without talking to them would
be but we won the division for five
years and just one second playoff game
we got to tweak the defense like we did
the offense last year and they need an
overhaul on the defense and they're not
that far off
so I'm guessing that's what they're
thinking but people here just livid that
they're not firing O'Brien that's the
poll question of John as we send them
throughout the rest of the day they're
without any moving violations course
what do you have over there hey John
here's our poll today who needs to win
this weekend the most Aaron Rodgers
Jimmy Garoppolo or Andy Reid
Andy raid Aaron Rodgers as one is
Superbowl Jimmy Garoppolo got plenty of
time to win a Super Bowl Andy Reid who
everybody loves I mean who doesn't like
Andy Reid this would be the greatest
time for Andrew Andy to win a Super Bowl
with Patrick mahomes and even though I'm
a little partial to the Titans I would
love to see Andy win it and I wish them
the best of luck three former Texans
coaches are in this these last four
games the only one is not is Andy Reid
we're the three for those who don't know
off the top of their head John rolling
green Green Bay and Kyle Shanahan they
were coaches under Gary Kubiak who I
interviewed this morning I'm writing a
column for tomorrow about them and then
of course Mike Brey will work for Bill
O'Brien so that's also very frustrating
to fans to see three of the former
assistants have a chance to go to the
Super Bowl
John hang in there man you got the
Rockets to root for and they look pretty
darn good so we'll chat soon
reg thank you very much as always I
really appreciate it always you're the
best man our one and only John McClain
at McLean underscore on underscore NFL
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on VR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app